You already know one language we've been using--the Python language obviously.
That has a syntax for statements and expressions,
but there are also some subparts of Python that seems like quite a different language.
One example would be the language for formatting strings.
Here's an example from the Python reference language.
You see that this rather bizarre string here with %(#)03D and so on.
There's a language of format strings itself to produce this type of output.
There are other parts of the Python language that allow you to customize it to your use.
You can create your own type of classes,
and they can have their own type of expression,
including operator overloading.
We're used to expressions like x + y.
Say if x is 2 and y is 3 then that would be 5.
But you can also say x + y where x and y are your own types of data types.
They might be matrices.
They might be components of some kind of building that you're building,
and this can say to put them together.
It may be two shapes that you can concatenate on the screen.
You can define your own language over the types of objects you want to deal with.
You can go one step farther than that and define your own domain specific language.
Here's an example.
This is a language for describing an optimization problem having to do with the price
on octane and various types of fuels,
and you can describe the parameters and then build the language processor
to take this as input and compute the output.
Of course, you could do that with a regular Python statement just as well,
but here what we've done is design the language specifically for this problem
and then written the problem description in that language.
In this unit we'll cover what is a language, what is a grammar,
the difference between a compiler and an interpreter,
and how to use languages as a design tool.